un nuevo golpe para la administración de
joe by de la corte suprema de estados
unidos bloqueó el mandato del presidente
para que los trabajadores de las
empresas con al menos 100 empleados se
vacuna en contra del cob y 19 o se
sometan a pruebas semanales y usen
mascarillas en el trabajo una medida que
habría impactado a más de 80 millones de
trabajadores me decepciona que el
tribunal supremo haya optado por
bloquear unos requisitos de sentido
común para salvar la vida de los
empleados de las grandes empresas que se
basaban directamente en la ciencia y en
la ley y continúan los traspiés para
bailén después de que el presidente
diera públicamente su apoyo a eliminar
el procedimiento de obstruccionismo
conocido como el filibustero dos
senadores de su propio partido kyrsten
sinema y joe manchin rechazaron dar su
respaldo a la iniciativa
estos proyectos de ley ayudarán a tratar
los síntomas de la enfermedad pero no
abordan plenamente la enfermedad en sí y
aunque sigo apoyando estos proyectos de
ley no apoyaré acciones separadas que
empeoren la enfermedad subyacente de la
división que afecta a nuestro país
algo que hunde la posibilidad de aprobar
los proyectos de ley sobre el al voto
impulsados desde la casa blanca
no sé si podremos conseguirlo pero sé
una cosa mientras tenga aliento en mí
mientras esté en la casa blanca mientras
esté comprometido en algo voy a estar
luchando para cambiar la forma en que se
mueven estas legislaturas tras un
difícil primer año en la casa blanca
bailén sigue enfrentando una crisis de
popularidad según el portal de
estadísticas fighter iv eight
actualmente joe biden cuenta con un 54
por ciento de desaprobación mientras que
tan sólo el 42,3 por ciento lo aprueba
la penosa salida de sus tropas de
afganistán la crisis migratoria en la
frontera y repunte de casos y
hospitalizaciones por ccoo y 19 le han
complicado el panorama esto de cara a
unas elecciones legislativas de medio
término donde las estrechas mayorías en
ambas cámaras se ven amenazadas